hey what's up guys it's Marcus rally
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
small unboxing video and when I say
small I actually do mean this quite
literally this is definitely the
smallest package I've ever received so I
do mean small quite literally guys see
the size of my knife right here the very
small knife you have this this is from
the kind folks at US v fever calm so
there link if you want to check it out
will be in the description and let's
just get right into this I probably
won't even need a knife if I just yeah I
can probably just go into this couple
guys this is a mini speaker the smallest
Speaker I have ever seen so if you have
seen a speaker smaller than this that
looks of any quality please let me know
because I want to check it out but this
is a small speaker I could find oh yes
there it is you guys can barely tell if
you were to see this box you would
probably not think there is a speaker
and there's their link right there USB
fever calm and nothing else really
so I'm guessing I'm guessing right now
I'm predicting it that there is just a
speaker and probably a USB cable in this
box that is my guess nothing there
yeah see bubble wrap already so here we
go guys this is just my unboxing on
first impressions then USB interesting
and the speaker itself Wow
okay and the box is empty so right off
the bat guys small speaker I've ever
seen by far just taking it out the
bubble wrap and I will have to pop this
later I apologize I will and this this
is it right here okay so first
impressions looks like Chrome to me
might actually be plastic we'll get into
that in the review video and here is
okay there's an on/off switch it's
automatically switched on so I'll just
turn that off and this USB cable looks
like it's going to plug right into here
if you want USB audio or you could take
this little thing right here I can get
this out of here this is the USB plug
your 3.5 millimeter USB plug
listen to your iPod so you have an iPod
Nano no speaker but you want to share
your music you can hold this in your
pocket guys quality speaker I'm going to
be reviewing this yes and let me go let
me know what format you guys want me to
review this in very small very small
speakers so you know small product small
review we'll see how it we'll see how it
goes so thanks for watching this
unboxing and first impressions video we
will definitely see this product in a
later video and uh that's long okay
thanks for watching guys peace